It is very important. I have a very beautiful city and before the
war it was very beautiful.
A lot of tourists came there
to rebuild everything that was lost and broken
before the war. I want our
fertile land to have
a lot of work.  it's a
pity with the war, we don't have the
opportunity not to work. I want to
restore all our houses, they were destroyed, not
like that, so that we could rebuild quickly, but
like it was in the pictures, we had a
good job, so that we had somewhere to go and
return home, but I hope that
our children will be able to live much better
than we lived,
that after the war we will be more united and
will have such a strong, beautiful, big
state that wants a stable, normal
life. I want to
wake up and drink coffee from my cup on the
balcony from the street.
the construction of factories, factories,
after all, if there will be any factories, factories,
then we will pay more taxes
that will go to our state, we will
be able to grow and develop, I
hope so